the long-awaited third season of The
Witcher is finally making its way to
Netflix starting in June 2023 and this
momentous for lots of reasons he is a
refresher before you dive into Henry
cavill's last hurray as geralt Netflix's
official log line of the third season
explains that geralts and Siri will
spend the least part of the season in
hiding as pursuers seek to capture the
young princess of sintra yennefer will
be with them too leading them into the
Fortress of aratuza as she investigates
series Powers yet the 2021 Luca comics
and games Festival showrunner Lauren
Schmidt his rig said the writers were
working on season three adding it's a
really fun season and it follows a
particular book very closely has a lot
of action some death some death his
regulator specified which book telling
Entertainment Weekly obviously we can't
do every page but time of contempt gave
us so many big action events plot points
the fighting character moments and huge
reveals of a big bad there's so much to
do that we were able to stick really
really closely with the books at 2022's
to Doom event Anya chalatra said we can
expect some tension between Jennifer and
Siri adding we've got a lot to learn
from each other
Henry Cavill Anya chalatra and Freya
Allen will all be back for season three
as geralt Jennifer and Siri although
this will be the last time we see Cavill
in the role he'll be replaced by Liam
Hemsworth in season four but his rig
told ew that the show will give caval
the most heroic send-off that we could
have in addition to the main Trio
Netflix also confirmed many actors from
season 1 and 2 are back including Joey
Beatty and Cassie Claire the streamer
also announced the addition of four new
members to the cast including Robbie
Amal who will play Gallatin the leader
of the scoia tell who will fight for
nilfgaard manga Zhang who fans may
remember from shangshi and the legend of
the ten Rings also joins the cast as
milva a Huntress of the broccolon forest
Hugh Skinner will play Prince radovid
the younger brother of Ed burch's King
vizimir lastly Crystal elwin will
portray missile a member of the thieving
rats group Lauren Schmidt his Rick is
back a showrunner for season three of
The Witcher after helming the previous
two fans of the book series should be
excited to have his Rick still around as
she's planning to take the series far at
Netflix when speaking with the rap in
December 2021 the showrunner said the
plan is to keep making The Witcher until
they have adapted all of author Andre's
subkovski's books she said I have always
said that I want to end our stories at
the same place that Andre sapkowski
ended his I just don't feel the need for
us to keep creating stories after his
intentional end the funny thing is of
course since we've been working on the
series it's actually released two new
books according to collider it looks
like his wreck is working on a seven
season plan
after what has felt like an eternity for
fans waiting for season 3 of The Witcher
to hit Netflix the release dates have
finally been set the first five episodes
of Henry cavill's final season as geralt
will premiere on June 29 2023 with the
last three episodes hitting the platform
on July 27th the third season was
announced in September 2021 tweet at the
same time Netflix also announced an
animated spin-off for kids yes a
children's show based on the TV MA
Witcher and a second animated film to
follow the Witcher and Nightmare of the
wolf we haven't seen much development on
those but the four episode prequel
series The Witcher blood origin debuted
on the platform on Christmas Day 2022
the fourth season of The Witcher with
Liam Hemsworth and the role of geralt
has also already been announced though
there has been a fair amount of backlash
around the casting change actor Joey
Beatty noted that it's more about love
for caval than hate for Hemsworth
telling it's gone viral the fans
appreciation for Cavalry it shows less
the intense side of it but more the the
the sheer affection and fondness and
love that they have for him at first
glance a new trailer for season 3
doesn't give fans a whole lot of
information to work with relying on
chilling narration from geralt over a
series of intriguing images it's a
master class in hyping an audience
without giving anything away but there
are still some tantalizing teasers for
starters Philippa eilhart seems to be
stepping into her villain origin story
and she threatens yaskia with a ring in
the shape of a Talon it's likely this
has something to do with Siri given that
her powers already turned her into a
serious Beacon for bad vibes speaking of
bad vibes it looks like reince will be
stepping in as a major antagonist once
more yennefer burns his face and left
him covered with serious scars so
chances are is not going to be on
friendly terms it's still not clear who
hired him to go after Siri in the first
season so there's still plenty of
mystery to him these are two of the
franchises fan favorite antagonists so
whatever they're up to it's likely not
good for Our Heroes for anyone who loves
this show but hasn't yet tried the books
somekowsky's novels gives far more space
to Gerald's complex in a world while TV
excels at showing the titular Witcher in
action the novels have the extra benefit
of delving into his philosophy around
his role the novel that's serving as the
basis for season 3 time of contempt
takes place between the two books Blood
of Elves and baptism of fire it follows
geralt giving everything to protect Siri
as a war between the northern kingdoms
and nilfgaard breaks out with Stakes at
an all-time high Jennifer attempts to
enroll Siri at the artuza school of
magic which audiences will recognize at
the school where Jennifer herself became
a mage under the tutelage of to Sayer
this inevitably goes awry leading to a
catastrophic chain of events for
yennefer to Sayer and tris meanwhile
geralt's efforts to keep Siri safe also
crumble and he is forced into battle
against vilgafort it's not likely the
series will follow this book to the
letter but it's part of the material
that should make for a truly great
season
first seen in season 2 the wild Hunt
will seemingly play a much bigger role
in the third season of The Witcher this
ominous group of specters serves as a
warning that war is brewing they kind of
feel like folklore when they're first
mentioned in the books and we wanted
that same feeling fans that skips The
Witcher blood origin might want to take
the time to watch the prequel series
before the beginning of season three
because there are some key details that
will come in handy as we learn more
about the group in blood origin the
captain of zintreya's army aerodym by
Art Glass is put in the ineviable
position of mediator between several
Elven despots drawing a serious power
shift he chooses and wisely to say the
least and ends up serving a cruel Empire
after the conjunction of the Spheres in
the books and video games he ends up
leading the red Riders a group of slave
Hunters tasked with capturing people to
serve King Oberon murstock with their
Insidious purpose their intimidating
armor and their spiritual appearance the
wild Hunt strikes Terror
it's very possible that the wild hunters
after Siri and to Elder blood after
season two it's hard to say where Siri
will be on an emotional level but
chances are she's been training with
gerals and Jennifer in hopes of
preventing further exploitation of her
power but as much as Jennifer might
develop a bond with Siri the two are
very different people at heart and it's
likely there will be problems in the
books the wild hunts becomes aware of
Siri very much by accident but it marks
a major turning point not just for her
but for aerodyne it's unlikely the show
will be able to fully cover the
complicated interactions between them in
one season but chances are we're going
to see some serious action when these
forces collide
over the first two seasons of the series
The Fearless geralt has become
increasingly more troubled as its
responsibilities a series of chords up
to him in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly showrunner Lauren
Schmidt his Rick explained that he'll be
even more vulnerable in season three
saying geralt's big turn is about giving
up neutrality and doing anything that he
has to to get to Siri now
for the first time
I understand real or fear according to
his wreck geralt will have a whole new
Mission by the start of the fourth
season where he'll be played by Liam
Hemsworth from all we know so far it
seems pretty likely that he and Siri
will be separated over the events of the
third season making his fear seem
tragically warranted though he avoided
taking Sirion as a pupil throughout much
of the first season fate brought them
together and it changed him how he's
going to deal with the threat of losing
her is something we'll have to find out
yennefer is one of the most morally
complicated characters in the show her
not so subtle Hedonism and tendency to
be Her Own Worst Enemy directly
challenged geralt's Moody philosophical
wanderings in season 2 she was left
powerless after her great feat at the
Battle of sodden Hill which opened the
door to temptation as she sought to
restore her former abilities as a mage
was ever the cast this Quest obscured
her sense of decency and led her down a
decidedly dark path as she made a deal
to deliver Cersei to the deathless
mother though she ultimately saw the
error of her ways and made a truly
heroic sacrifice that saved Siri Gary
Walt's trust in her is understandably
damaged it's unlikely that he'll stay
mad at her forever but it's not the sort
of thing one can easily forget in the
trailer we see her sporting The Familiar
masks she wore during the first season
episode bottled appetite it's an
accessory with a lot of meaning to say
the least one huge reveal in the second
season of The Witcher was that series
father long believed to be dead is
actually alive and well although we
first meet Siri during the fall of her
family's Kingdom them gradual Clues have
dropped to indicate that nothing is
quite as it seems Gerald's first met
series grandmother Queen kalanthi in the
first season during the betrothal party
of her daughter pavetta the Vetter is
Overjoyed when her true love Dooney who
is not a betrothed but isn't a
porcupine-like humanoid form breaks up
the celebration Queen kalanthi is
extremely not cool about this but osmo
Lee garot saves dooney's life the
emergence of pavetta's powers makes it
clear that this is one couple that's
going to stay together after geralt
jokes about his payment I
playing the tradition as you have
the Lord of surprise
give me that majority have but do not
know paveza's pregnancy with Siri is
revealed and the Geraldton series Fates
are forever intertwined Dooney and
poveta were beliefs who have perished
but we recently saw that he actually
survived and became the Emperor of
nilfgaard we're on the edge of our seats
wondering how he transformed from friend
into domineering King
the TV adaptation of The Witcher kicked
off with a tense fight scene and the
hits have kept coming from then on out
while we see Garrow preparing to fight
more than we see him actually juking it
out in the trailer there are a few
indicators That season 3's brawls are
going to be quite the spectacle already
in full which a form in the opening
sequence and Vanishing has played with
fearsome intent geralt looks ready for
the fight of his life fans of The
Witcher video games might have noticed
that the trailer shows a new green
runestone fixed to geralt's Blade
indicating that there might be a gear
upgrade on the horizon there's also the
question of who exactly would have
required him to seek out such a power
boost the options are plentiful running
the gamut through just about every major
villain who has appeared in the series
to date as well as some friends will he
be squaring off against Dooney
bilgefortz yennefer the other witches
even without knowing for sure who the
target of his Ayah happens to be this
promises to be a fight for the Aegis
Lauren Schmidt his Rick has noted that
neither She nor the writers were aware
that the season will be broken up into
two chunks a month apart but it ended up
working out pretty well for the flow of
the Season as Rick explained on
Netflix's blog to Doom for any fans who
are familiar with the time of contempt
novel there's an epic event that
explodes the continent as we know it the
lead up to which provided a perfect
Cliffhanger for us it's Rick also
reiterated that the events of the season
will weigh heavily on geralt while he
was able to assert neutrality and deny
his emotions before things have changed
drastically for him she said he can't
pretend that he doesn't feel he can't
pretend that he's impenetrable
foreign